[Music]
when I was a kid I remember look at this
and I look what is this black magic
people come up with these builders and I
just have no reason they just like you
but it works like but why okay Eddie has
created things that will probably change
education forever and at least something
they're always going to charge you
interest you're going to say oh that's
cool I'll just pay a devalued okay ha ha
ha joke's on you we'll just charge of
interest going it's difficult to
understand really how someone in Sydney
can influence the outcomes of people
across the whole country we love him to
become either a doctor or a lawyer said
me Eddie could have been any one of
those things and that heaps of money but
he's chosen to be a teacher I've given
you hundreds of HSC questions what's
something you would feel confident
explaining in front of other people he
[ __ ] me in don't to say that he's
actually into math
I think that that wakes me up in the
morning and makes me roll out of bed is
that every day I'm gonna stay in front
of 24 students every single one had a
journey behind it an interesting story
and that just is youth every time this
is my tenth year teaching and I love my
subject there is a shortage of
mathematics teachers they're in high
demand
good boy and this is anywhere from
cheerio technology high school falling
hey going it would be lovely to get up
to clone Eddie whoo so that you had a
range of him in school
come in grab a seat and if you have your
devices there get your devices out I've
met many students who have come to me
and polite as they are will walk into my
classroom first day of the year and
they'll say look sir no offense I just
want you to know I don't do maths
there's a lot more to math than just
numbers right so I view that kind of
student as my personal mission to turn
around if she didn't already know I
record my lessons I record all them in
fact about to record this one I've
always hated math I don't think I had
the brain for it at all I would sit
doing homework and mostly end up in
tears because it can understand it it
never made sense for me and I think not
making sense just it made me so angry
I'd like to say mathematics never came
instinctively for me which is why now I
sort of know is that just because
mathematics doesn't come naturally that
doesn't mean you can't work with it and
I come to an understanding of it often
we give up well this is the taxable
income
way back when come I said I'm going to
drop it this is the worst thing I have
much other things that we want to do my
time
so I think the hard part is question is
there's so much information I implored
her to continue and one of the ways that
I did that was just to help explain to
her well ok look let's go back to the
point where you did understand and even
some of the most oppositional students
once they get a taste of what it's like
to be able to solve a question they fall
in love too is there anyone who still
doesn't have their name down I call it
he is I always called him fat chocolate
if you had to pick one got to pick one
initially I didn't know that is had so
much interest in maths that he would
want to teach it
my brother has has made a very
surprising kind of trajectory of his own
but none of us really expected
[Music]
my parents attorney and Angela they were
both born in Malaysia and they moved to
Australia largely because the education
system in Malaysia and many of you
opportunities for people growing up in
Malaysia are extremely limited
I came here when I was just about 19 and
don't know anybody it was quite tough
first year especially very tough for you
because of the of the accent problem we
couldn't understand most of us and
definitely fading them the Aussie accent
my mum did work when she was back in
Malaysia as a newsreader she could speak
English fluently also Cantonese Mandarin
bahasa melayu 16 17 different languages
or dialects my parents sacrificed a lot
to come to Australia because my mum was
leading a career
my dad was leading his family my brother
sister and I were born we were raised
here in Australia they were very very
insistent that we made English our first
language I can speak Cantonese and
Mandarin in a very cursory way so I can
count I can describe foods I can say my
name
but that marks basically the extensive I
certainly couldn't have a conversation
in Chinese which makes me a little bit
sad because I know that's part of my
history
[Music]
then wanting us to speak English came
back to them not wanting us to be
singled out as immigrants for us to be
deeply upon this culture to belong here
[Music]
anyways when I go on playground dude I
go out nicely these hundreds of children
roaming around and I watch for the
students who don't have a group of
friends or even the ones who do but I
can tell they're at the fringes I think
that growing up racism was something
which I definitely felt around me in the
late 70s and 80s they want a lot of
Asian families in our areas so to us you
know we we fought Australian but we just
looked Chinese
they're ignorant they try and learn our
customs or our language or anything else
I think there's just too many of them
[Music]
when I was in primary school they used
to sing little rhymes rich from
occasions and I used to seen them and I
didn't realize what it actually meant
until they'd are there overtaken school
or men they carried pen knives and
everything they go on bash up girls and
rape girls and everything
I remembered someone nearly got me down
the street ching chong [ __ ] once
upon a time and I'd been called I've
been called [ __ ] the people who I spend
time with at school you know sometimes
they would they would beat me up because
I was little because they could there
were days when I would not want to go to
school because that was what I knew was
waiting for me my mum she would buy me
books and I really treasured those books
people in my class who didn't like me
knew how much I loved those books
sometimes they would find them and they
would steal them and I would find them
out in the playground
you know all dirty and covered in dust
or ripped up so that is a discrimination
be suffered you had to put up with as a
move I still remember you know my
parents said to me this this happens and
it's our role to enjoy that and know
that sometimes life is not fair I only
have one rule in my classroom and I call
it the human rule very simple I will
treat you like humans and I expect you
to treat me like a human to one of the
most important qualities of a teacher is
to be compassionate so you got an answer
but it was all of it okay let's try and
like our haven't it's the difficult kids
the kids you don't seek out your help
the kids who are reserved you're going
to multiply both of them by 750 I know
the kids who need help most because I
was one of those
[Music]
mom and dad put a lot of emphasis on
education they wanted us to study hard
which i think is quite coming from
migrant families out of the three of us
is went straight into James ruse high
school which is selective James ruse is
the cream of the crop for all students
my parents thought that they had struck
gold
they had seen that other children who
had gone to selected high schools had
come out and become the leaders of the
world the lawyers the solicitors the the
engineers the politicians maybe these
are occupations that gives you good
incomes so to speak and also sort of
more status my brother then said I am
going to choose education I want to be a
teacher and the air was heavy then you
really could cut the air with a knife
you really could hear a pin drop we sort
of said we really look at each other
there what what is it doing what is it
they said you know why why do you think
we've come to this country for what do
you think was the purpose of us leaving
behind all our families in our
pre-established life did you think we
came here for the web ha or for the
politics or for what was it even though
I could not understand that was so
important to him I just let it let it be
let him do what he wants my mum was a
little different
she said Eddie over my dead body but
Eddie stuck to his guns I really wanted
to do something which I I saw my skills
really lined up well with and I just the
more I thought about it the more I
realized this is the direction I want to
go
you know KMS what comes of it now shape
man we call it our problem right it's a
shape in every single object made when I
saw it through the air like that's a
part of like a pill it's just one of two
teachers that changed the mind of a
child good sections of all related to
get out mathematically mister best in
mr. Brown they were teachers that
inspired him to become a teacher a
mulberry tree growing in sugar one of
the deepest memories I have is of my
agriculture teacher in year 7 mr. Brown
and the poetry Hilton yes well I didn't
it is quite an establishment we were
walking down to the school farm and he
turned to me and he said Edward how are
you today and I kind of paused because
I'd never been asked a question like
that by an adult before and I thought is
this is this a test I just saw teachers
cared for their students and that made a
really deep impression big part of being
a teacher is trying like the kids feel
they counted and they were important and
I feel like that's the thing which I
gained from both of you
now that I am a teacher a lot Eddie
always struck me as being a very
enthusiastic student but the last two
years of high school he went through
that all of the trauma of having his
mother very ill in his senior years
[Music]
I was in year ten when my mother was
diagnosed with lung cancer she was not a
smoker she was healthy in every way was
very fit and so it came as a complete
shock to all of us she's not the type of
woman who give up easily to struggle and
struggle I have the distinct memory of
lots of nights spent sitting beside the
bed 11 p.m. 1:00 a.m. 3:00 a.m. because
she would need someone to be able at a
moment's notice because when you can't
breathe
you can't breathe to be able to quickly
act and help her bring her whatever she
needs it had to be me because there was
no one else in the family who could do
it somehow a mum passed away is grew up
really fast was a very difficult period
for all of us and he was youngest and
somehow he was like a rock
and I get a bit emotional when I look at
your mum yeah I was an emotional wreck
it was him virtually the reason for my
living he would have been comforting me
and holding my shoulders that hanging
the you be right
she sa young he was only 19 years old he
knows how to comfort the father and I
said my god I wanted to be someone who
could be brave it's been a long time
that yes it is and not give over to
others that burden of having to care for
me because I was a mess um I wanted to
be able to hold things together because
I saw I swipe every falling apart around
me and I do someone had to be strong
when I look back at it what I think it
was was his Christianity and his faith
in God that he would meet mum one day
again in heaven
it makes Eddie the person he is today
having gone through the death of his mum
I think it's made him more empathetic to
people who have an illness in 2012 I had
a student in one of my classes who was
very ill he was diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer and he was away from
school for huge chunks of time getting
treatment I still had it as a keen
memory how much of my later years in
high school had been deeply affected by
a cancer and and what that did to my
education and so I felt very personally
that I should do something about this
and I came to that realization that
actually we have technology now which
can help with this why don't I just take
my phone and then when my lessons
started I just hit record so one two
three definitions now Sigma notation
like this middle one all my other
students noticed that I was doing this
and they said hey what's that about sir
and sure enough they started to watch
and they started passing the links for
the videos to their friends in other
classes and then those students started
to meet with friends from other schools
worship is honestly a lifesaver
I can't tell you how many times like
before math exams people would be on woo
tube looking up videos for topics that
they don't understand and then as soon
as they watch the video then like ahh
it makes sense now I can do this test if
you later
anywhere who makes these videos free for
anyone and that's a really quality issue
they're available for anyone anytime
anywhere and that's really exciting
[Music]
Koba is a very small Outback town our
populations around 5,000 people we're a
mining town and we've got three schools
two primary and one secondary I feel
free to choose the political character I
love most because it solves problems you
have to go backwards before you split it
up again I had a really awesome math
teacher myself at high school and I feel
like yeah I'm going to I'm going to get
a uni of Alaska teacher when you knew
that you're going to be now was dividing
so basically on the waters down to media
division one of my major problems with
math when I struggling with it was that
I didn't understand the first steps and
I would cause a chain reaction with the
second step third step the fourth step
and you're grading ears two or three yes
you know it hasn't been my favorite
subject but I would like to go to
university and maybe do some sort of a
business degree but and I feel like some
basic sant knowledge of math is
important there we've just been doing
practice questions what are you doing
with your year 12 class I think of
something interesting and exciting to do
it in tomorrow it's hard to get teachers
out here that might be a little bit
different so I might marry three of
always to explain a topic but it hasn't
clicked with the students
can we walk in this for a second now
you've seen this before I wonder if I
can bring that other teacher in in the
form of an anywhere video he can explain
it again
[Music]
I just got the Wi-Fi to Google about
saying simultaneous equations any room
and then it comes out take whatever is
five cool
yay I feel like in math I can use it at
home I won't don't need to travel or pay
for it just remove those barriers that
hold us back sometimes with due to
isolation
[Music]
I don't know where he finds the time you
talk to him it's going Oh had a mouse or
to go to this thing and going to
interview panel for health school I got
bored this video as this and I'm going
to start making practicing with you guys
and then I'll like get sick and I go
take him to the doctor something there's
24 hours in the day to you right it's
not more the whole fire all right he's
going to go first he really works hard
at making family time family time and
work life work life what was that hair
blue Nathan your terminus when he gets
home he really prioritizes time with our
children huh I often have ribbed
sometimes out of good humor sometimes
not about how teachers have lots of
times off from school and isn't that
lovely to have so many holidays if it's
school holidays you'll often find me at
the hospital
I've heard of easing me shopping to go
to the hospital middle of the night
because one of the children have had a
like an allergic reaction or or an
asthma chuckle so severe we like Nathan
to eat lots of over the next six or
eight weeks then at some point after
that we'll do another upper endoscopy
there really could not be a better
example of a family that has the full
hand of allergic diseases I'm a-goin he
does still say my tummy hurt
studies show that if you are the
Australian born child of two parents
born in Asia as both Eddie and Michelle
are your chances of having eczema
compared with children with two
Australian born parents are about double
and we'll get a scope organising yeah I
remember my mum would send me to school
covered in band-aids very soon seven or
eight band-aids across my hands because
I would just scratch at them and they
would just bleed and my face would be
all swollen and puffy because I was
constantly scratching there's such a
strong genetic component the word
children really are sitting ducks for
allergic disease Emily is allergic to a
long list of foods that includes milk
nuts and fish Jamie
he has immediate type food allergies and
eczema of Eddie and Michelle's three
children I would say Nathan is the most
severely affected by allergic disease at
four months old I knew something was not
right he had really bad eczema all over
his skin we had to get the nurses out
every day to help us wrap his body like
a mummy
when Nathan was between nine and twelve
months he started losing weight at 18
months old he started vomiting randomly
Nathan was diagnosed with a very rare
condition called
he is an affiliate esophagitis swallow
this is something which even many
doctors haven't heard of know in a while
since you had this one the difficulties
are everyday for him eating itself has
become a really difficult experience
because when he was younger
eating was associated with an incredible
amount of discomfort and pain just to
squeeze food and drink down his
esophagus he was classified as failure
to thrive which means he wasn't growing
because he wasn't getting enough
nutrients
he'd 6ne weighs less than a typical
three-year-old and if you put him in a
room with 200 other children his age he
would be shorter than 199 of them have
the PD back I'm getting to woody it's
just a concern for me when I think about
Nathan growing up knowing that he's
always going to be a little sad a little
nervous for him knowing that he'll
always stand out a little bit because of
his size you probably like your toys too
since becoming a parent what they do
when you leave the room that's really
colored everything's about the way that
I approach my work as a teacher he wants
the best for our kids and in the same
way he understands that the parents of
his students want the best for their
children
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if I can't have you the message either
they go to vivica the team whatever
Eddie results are always really straight
we had a student last ship you've got a
hundred literally 100 in their extension
one HSC TM which is fairly no if it
doesn't happen I could say actually in
2016 I taught this boy and when I was
hundreds of dead it's possibly even
being so good so much goes on around you
that celebrates the work that he got I
literally never seen a gator eternal now
our final tweets do today from cheerio
Technical High School where is a maths
teacher but he's also an internet
sensation this guy is the Kim Kardashian
of ascribe mathematics teaching as far
as I'm concerned this is Eddie whoo
there is no doubt that teach this
generally changed rise and somebody of
motivated and as wonderful as Eddie
undoubtedly would five you all of these
awards as part of raising the profile of
education helping people recognize that
teaching matters and it deserves the
best people food we could press into its
service I can see the pride anywhere he
tells me then another student has gone
into teaching one to be honest I never
really considered teaching math until I
have mister as a teacher
I finished my HSC last year with m8r of
99 point - my mom expected me to do law
but my passions were in education so
there are definitely a lot of parallels
between masoor story and my story
mom always used to teach me how to cut
these properly because I could never do
it
women if we went through the stage where
we wanted to get all her recipes down on
paper yeah this is the recipe book
family recipe book and how I kept my
culture alive and that's how we kept mum
alive basically through through cooking
Alisha can cook most of it I can cook
like moving properly three actual dishes
including this one brahmand from that
from what from what she could make any
mum not being around to see the kind of
teacher that he is really sad she would
have been so proud of him
[Music]
I'd like to think that she'd be proud of
me I really feel as third part of what
it means to be kind of son in an Asian
family is that honoring our parents
really matters I'm very proud but I was
afraid I might be both who there was the
only thing that I I have to be Asian
conscious or sometimes we see all your
son's show your famous just tony son so
I've become well known because of my own
son the success that I've been able to
experience its his success
it's the ratification of why he
sacrificed what he had willed his family
and his security in Malaysia why he gave
all that up to come here it was worth it
[Music]